[Música]
ya lo decíamos hoy en directo a vamos a
Caracas la capital venezolana donde hoy
se produjo la restauración de la mesa de
diálogo entre el gobierno el estado
colombiano y la guerrilla de lln esta
ciudad será la sede de las negociaciones
en medio de la polémica que genera
Venezuela Al haber sido señalado en
repetidas ocasiones de dar refugio A
integrantes de este grupo delincuencial
a esta hora conectamos con Daniela
Zambrano corresponsal de France 24 en
Caracas Daniela Cuáles son los
resultados de esta jornada de
restauración de los diálogos
en esta oportunidad ambas partes
acordaron reanudar el proceso de diálogo
con plena voluntad política y ética
cierre es el comunicado que leyeron las
partes y también Construir la paz a
partir de una democracia con justicia
una de las consultas que se le hizo a
los jefes de los equipos negociadores
fue precisamente el tema de la amnistía
y sobre esto respondió el alto
comisionado para la paz de Colombia
Danilo Rueda que no había nada definido
en este punto pero garantizaba que no
iba a haber impunidad y los derechos de
las víctimas iban a ser respetados con
respecto al ambiente de este primer
encuentro ya formal para la reanimación
de los diálogos se pronunció OTI Patiño
que recordemos milito en la guerrilla
del m-19 él decía que había bastante
sintonía entre las partes y que se podía
hablar de confianza a primera vista
Pablo berrotará Pablo Disculpen por
parte del equipo del Ln decía que ellos
no estaban pidiendo nada a cambio que
esta mesa no se trataba de un trueque
pues ya le habían consultado en otras
oportunidades si cuantos curules iba a
querer el Ln y él dijo que no se trataba
de eso que precisamente eso era lo que
había que cambiar en Colombia este
encuentro se llevó a cabo en el hotel
Humboldt en el Ávila fue una reunión
privada en primera instancia y
posteriormente fue el pronunciamiento
conjunto con la prensa Daniela Venezuela
coge estas negociaciones tras cuatro
años congeladas Cuál es el papel que
juega Venezuela se puede considerar Un
regreso a la escena diplomática
internacional
analistas coinciden en que no hubiese
sido posible este acercamiento entre el
gobierno colombiano y el Ln sin la
intervención de Venezuela pero más
precisamente si la intervención de
Nicolás maduro pues se ha denunciado en
múltiples oportunidades y ya lo decías
tanto organizaciones no gubernamentales
como políticos sobre la fuerte presencia
que tiene el Ln en territorio venezolano
Venezuela funge como país garante junto
a Cuba y junto a Noruega y en esta
primera oportunidad estos diálogos se
van a extender hasta mediados de
diciembre se esperaría que la próxima
Ronda de negociaciones sería a partir de
enero y podría ser en la sede en algunos
de los otros países garantes sin embargo
el rol de Venezuela es fundamental lo
reconocieron las partes pero al ser
consultados sobre precisamente la
presencia de la guerrilla lln en
territorio venezolano y las denuncias
sobre crímenes que han cometido
evitarnos responder directamente esta
pero el alto comisionado para la paz de
Colombia así fue enfático en decir que
los las conversaciones que se habían
dado al interno del Ln para la
renovación de estos diálogos habían sido
en territorio colombiano y no en
territorio venezolano